we have a lot of Swedish sayings that
are very commonly used and it's one of
those things when it's my own language I
didn't really think about how weird they
are but saying in Swedish well now
you've taken a poop in the blue cabinet
yeah
it's like a very common thing or like
yeah you can't just expect yourself you
know to walk in here like sliding in on
a shrimp sandwich
can't come in here and slide on a shrimp
sandwich
you know in a socialist country having a
shrimp sandwich is very fancy so it's
not like you can't just have your
privileges and walk in slide in here on
a shrimp sandwich we have an Australian
one uh we're not here to [__] spiders
[__]